i will now do a proof of the law of
sines so let's say let me draw
an arbitrary triangle
let's see that's one side right there
and then i get another side here and
i'll try to make it look a little
strange so you realize it can apply to
any triangle
and let's say we know
we know
the following information
we know this angle
well actually i'm not going to say what
we know or don't know but i'm going to
the law of sines is just a relationship
between different angles and different
sides so let's say that this angle right
here is alpha
the side here is a the length here is a
let's say that this side here is
beta and that the length here is b right
b beta is just you know b with a long
end there so let's see if we can find a
relationship that connects
a and b and alpha and beta
so what can we do so let me draw and and
hopefully that that relationship we find
will be the law of sines
otherwise i have i would have to rename
this video so let's let me draw an
altitude here so i think that's the
proper term
so if i
if i just draw a line from this side
coming straight down and it's going to
be perpendicular to this uh bottom side
which i haven't labeled but you know
i'll probably if i have to label it
probably label it c because that's a and
b
and this is going to be a 90 degree
angle
this is going to be a 90 degree angle
and i don't know
i don't know the length of that i don't
know anything about it all i know is i
i took a i i went from this vertex and i
dropped a line that forms a 92 that's
perpendicular to this other side
so what can we do with this line well
let me just say that it has length x
the length of this line is x
so we can can we find a relationship
between
a
the length of this line x and beta
well sure let's see
let me
find an appropriate
appropriate color
okay that's i think a good color
so what's a relationship
for if we look at this angle right here
beta x is opposite to it and a is a
hypotenuse if we look at this right
triangle right here right
so what deals with opposite and
hypotenuse so i'm here always whenever
we do trigonometry we should always just
write sohcahtoa at the top of the page
sokatoa so what deals with opposite and
hypotenuse
sine right so and you should probably
guess that because i'm proving the law
of sines
so let's see the sine of beta
the sine
of beta
is equal to the opposite over the
hypotenuse so it's equal to this
opposite which is x
over the hypotenuse which is a in this
case
and then if we wanted to solve for x and
i'll just do that because it'll be
convenient later we can multiply both
sides of this equation by a and you get
a
sine
of beta
is equal to x
fair enough that got us someplace
let's see if we can find a relationship
between alpha b and x
well similarly if we look at this right
triangle because this is also a right
triangle of course
what deals x here relative to alpha is
also the opposite side and b now is a
hypotenuse so we can also write we can
also write that
sine of alpha let me do a different
color
sine
of alpha is equal sine of alpha is equal
to opposite over hypotenuse opposite
over hypotenuse the opposite is x
and the hypotenuse is b
the hypotenuse
is b and let's solve for x again just to
do it multiply both sides by b and you
get
b
sine
of alpha is equal to x so now what do we
have we have two different ways that we
solved for this
this thing that i dropped down from this
side this x right we have a sine of beta
is equal to x
and that b sine of alpha is equal to x
well if they're both equal to x and
they're both equal to each other so let
me write that down
let me write that down in a soothing
color
so we know that a
sine
of beta
is equal to right a sine of b is equal
to x which is also equal to b sine of
theta
sorry b sine of alpha
b sine
of alpha if we divide both sides of this
equation by
a what do we get we get sine
of beta right because the a on this side
cancels out is equal to b
sine
of alpha over a and if we divide both
sides of
this equation by b we get
sine
of beta
over
b
is equal to
sine of beta over is equal to sine
of alpha
over a so this is the law of sines
the the ratio between the sine of beta
and its opposite side and it's you know
the side that it corresponds to this b
is equal to the ratio of the sine of
alpha and its opposite side and then you
know a lot of times in the books if
let's say this angle was theta and this
was c then you know they would also
write that's also equal to the sine of
theta
sine of theta over c and and
the proof of adding this here is
identical i mean we we picked b
arbitrarily b is the side we could have
done the exact same thing with theta and
c but instead of drawing the altitude
dropping the altitude here we would have
had to drop one of the other altitudes
and
you i think you could figure out that
part but the important thing is we have
this ratio and of course you could have
written it you since it's a ratio you
could flip both sides of the ratio you
could write it
b
over the sine of b
is equal to
a
over the sine of alpha
and this is useful because if you know
if if you know
one side at its corresponding angle the
angle opposite it that kind of opens up
into that side and say you know the
other side then you could figure out the
angle that opens up into it or i mean
well you could if you know three of
these things you can figure out the
fourth and that's what's useful about
about the law of sines
so uh maybe now i will do a few law of
sines word problems i'll see in the next
video